[Music]
hey what up y'all welcome back to hcl we
are in hollywood i got the answers and
the answers this morning is mother
majesty thank you for being here mother
majesty thank you for having me
yeah now before the break we heard your
song uh she nominated from the new hit
album girl army oh yeah yeah
well thank you so much scratch you know
this whole album is about girls and
empowering girls and you know kind of
just showing girls they can be strong
and powerful and do what they want to do
and not what the media says they need to
do
all right all right that's deep that's
steve now we got some uh young females
here we have some questions for you uh
is that okay oh it's always okay it's
always okay i always want to give my
girl army hi majesty it is so cool to
meet you thank you so much i think
you're beautiful just like that
um
yeah so okay last week i took your
advice from your song get some and i
flaunted it till he wanted it
but i ended up losing my virginity to a
guy that i don't know you see it is time
for girls to take back the power
nowadays cause it's your body and it's
your mind and you should use that to
feel sexy and empowered
okay yeah yeah but now i'm pregnant
miracles next question
hi hi majesty i'm cassie i think your
album rocks thank you so much cassie i
think you should never change your skin
okay
so in your song friday night freak down
thank you so much cassie
you say bend it over touch the ground
he'll ride you like his merry-go-round
yes i do
is that about butt sex what it's about
cassie is us reclaiming our bodies as
women because you know for a long time
being sexy was about being sexy for a
man but this is about being sexy for
yourself
but i've got herpes in my butt okay
let's
change tracks for a second we gonna go
to commercial when we come back mother
majesty is going to unfurl her new song
what is it about oh okay it's a it's
kind of a love song and it's about
finding strength after having your heart
broken all right we gonna go to
commercial when we come back mother
majesty with who got next on this
blackberry pie
[Music]
here's your dressing room your majesty
thank you so much
[Music]
ah
[Music]
that's right girls being overly sexual
and being strong are the same thing
it's the same thing
it's the same
thing
[Laughter]
girl power
oh god
i'm allergic to this makeup
now why would i have burped
that's weird
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
baby how could this feeling be wrong
sometimes the thing that you've been
searching for
has been right there the whole time
so baby i'm here to tell ya i'm waiting
right here just to make you all my
[Music]
and i always been here baby standing
right here by your side
[Applause]
yes
been building up inside of me
and i just gotta come out
[Music]
and tell you what i'm feeling girl tell
you all love is what i'm talking about
[Music]
that's where you belong
[Applause]
[Music]
slow the way you've never done before
open up your mind i will open up your
door i've been searching all around for
the one i can't call mine sometimes the
thing you're searching for has been
there the whole time
[Music]
[Music]
standing right in front of you
nothing left to hide you sugar say i'm
telling you everything i've kept very
deep inside
i'm rubbing up against your
there's no one else i could be possibly
talking about cause you are bald and you
are here
[Music]
you
you're a woman i'm a man now you
and you know that's how i like it
and i'm specifically talking about you
because you're a girl and i am the
opposite
woman woman woman woman woman
you are a woman i am a man
you know i like women
because i am a man
never liked a man in my life
and i don't like one now
[Music]
baby baby
it looks like we're back together
and it's like nothing had ever
torn us apart
[Music]
so tonight i'm gonna hit that
tonight i'm gonna hit that
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just get into my car
and i'll take you so far
from where anyone can see
let's just walk and take it slow
in crowded places so they'll know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
i'm sorry
that was an involuntary reaction
who you gonna call
[Music]
hi i'm ray parker jr writer and
performer of the academy award nominated
his single
ghostbusters from the major motion
picture ghostbusters but that's just one
song i've written so many other major
motion picture theme songs and submitted
them throughout the years
now they're available and together for
one specially priced compilation
songs like you tried to play the game
but it's driving you insane
jumanji
danger in the jungle jumanji
there's lying in my house
come on mr computer
throw me a bone i said lawn
[Music]
watch out behind you that's trying to
find you pelican briefs
it's getting legal y'all these songs
have only been heard by the highest
level of industry decision makers but
now you can feel like a hollywood
executive in your own home
i see your face off
that guy walking around it's a face off
that ain't even your face
pass another christ
give me that off for this
[Music]
[Music]
now there's a whole lot of kinky that
that room is stinky 50 shades of grey
all right white people
who's a slave
i'm not a slave
12 years i sleep
[Music]
there's one thing i know is that
persistence makes perfection
sure hollywood missed out
but that doesn't mean you have to
down in the basement
what's going on
it's uh
[Music]
there's a kid and a nazi down there
[Music]
order now to receive your free copy of
bobby sings the twos theme songs to
sequels that were never
[Music]
a
made
and it shines within the darkness of the
sands of time
there's our fight
but the battle to be won is with the man
inside
[Music]
nothing will keep it from getting to you
[Music]
like a dream
you can never tell the lies from what
is
[Music]
let the music in your heart give way to
the things that you believe
[Music]
[Applause]
you can never tell the lies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rhythms i believe
is the power
of wings
[Music]